any riddled with anxiety I live in the
city I don't have a car I just walk
around everywhere uh you guys ever do
this one you guys ever leave the house
without headphones
thoughts are not good
my God this whole time I thought I love
music turns out I just hate my brain
just being attacked all day long with
his insecurity playlist on shuffle ah
what are you doing with your life you
drink too much gonna die alone you call
that a penis
hahaha
my brain never stops I can't sleep at
night I'm a horrible sleeper that's why
I hate these big commercials you see at
4 AM hey you can't sleep well how come
is your mattress what's your sleep
number how's your firmness you think
lack of comfort would keep me up at
night and that's a problem really that's
this goddamn Japanese game show I got
going up here right
yes the worry the anxiety The Dread I
don't need a mattress designed by NASA I
need a Xanax of some self-esteem all
right
come on Comfort I can sleep on a gravel
road if I had a good childhood